what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with spider-verse and you guys
really seem to enjoy the last video that
we did so we're going to do more uh this
one in particular is very very
interesting so here's one thing that i
want to preface before we we get into
this there are a few things going on
within the marvel universe and
multiverse at the same time this is
happening and that actually lead up to
it specifically the events of infinity
so basically thanos fighting the
inhumans and the terrorism bomb as well
as the incursions we'll explain that
once we get to it but the other thing is
that following this we're going to jump
into edge of spider-verse and edge of
spider-verse is where you get a lot of
the origins you guys have been asking
for right so like the origin of
spider-gwen different things like that
so what kind of bring all that stuff
together and then once edge of spidey
verse finishes we'll get into the actual
main spider-verse event because this is
all prelude stuff
this is all the stuff leading up to
quote-unquote the main spider-burst
event and so what this does is this
actually focuses at least in this video
we're going to be focusing on amazing
spider-man vol 3. now the reason why
that matters is because technically the
events of superior spider-man concluded
they're done and when superior
spider-man ended you went into amazing
spider-man 3 which was basically peter
parker getting his body back the reason
why you still see superior spider-man is
because prior to the ending of his story
spider-verse took place so he was thrown
into the multiverse he's currently
outside of time so it's like dr octopus
taking over the body of peter parker on
a monday the entire spider-verse event
happens on a tuesday and then on a
wednesday peter gets his body back so
it's just one of those one of those
weird things right it's just something
to wrap your head around i know it seems
a little strange but what this also does
is it brings in a character named cindy
moon now cindy moon was a really really
cool concept that marvel wasted
and it really kind of sucked so if you
guys recall our discussion about the
idea of spider totems again that was
marvel basically moving away from the
idea that peter parker was just a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and instead him being bitten by that
spider basically tied him into this kind
of mystical
connection that he had with all these
other people who had been bitten by
spiders and become spider people now one
of the things that marvel had did is
they had an event called original sin
and all original sin did is it basically
revealed all these things that we never
knew about it was a way for marvel to
kind of jump start stories they'd been
looking to tell and you learned some
really really cool stuff right captain
america being part of the illuminati and
then having his mind wiped and kicked
out different things along those lines
cindy moon was actually a girl who was
bitten by the exact same spider that bit
peter parker and in fact they happened
within like minutes of each other this
fighter bit peter it fell off and then
it bits cindy on her ankle the kicker to
this is that if you recall our
discussions about like ezekiel sims and
all those guys basically ezekiel sims
realizing that like the inheritors were
going around and killing people who were
basically spider-man and spider-woman
from across the multiverse that when he
encountered cindy moon and her power
started manifesting he realized that the
inheritors were after her and so what he
did is he locked her away in what was
basically a bunker that had years worth
of food now she wasn't a prisoner she
could have left at any point in time she
had the access code to leave but ezekiel
sims basically said if you do that
there's a good chance they'll find you
and they will kill you if they do right
there's no way you can fight them off on
your own so she was more of a prisoner
by choice than anything else following
the events of original sin and peter
parker learning of cindy moon's
existence he basically rescued her then
there was like a whole series of events
where she was pissed off but because of
the fact that she's part of the spider
totems and she has the name the bride
essentially her and peter parker just
can't stop banging that's really what it
means like if they are in a vicinity of
each other like literally it happens
here we're like they're talking he's
showing her the internet and he's like
okay when you were locked away yeah it
was aol and netscape for those of you
guys who were that old to remember that
kind of stuff i do i remember aol
[Laughter]
but he says like nowadays it's all
facebook and all that kind of stuff
they're literally within a foot of each
other the pheromones start kicking in
and they want to start banging and it
happened for a while when they first met
they couldn't stop banging it was crazy
it was hilarious but it was crazy and so
again with anna maria marconi being here
of course again her she initially met dr
octopus believing he was peter parker
all that stuff took place during
superior spider-man that she's like okay
no we're not having you guys doing this
this is not gonna happen uh she starts
literally starts spraying him with water
in order to make him stop
and so cindy moon finally gives up and
she ends up basically taking off to find
her own place now following that what
you actually end up getting is this
great big huge kind of calamity where
you basically have minerva the reason
why this matters is like minerva
fighting the cops and things like that
it's not overall important to the
spider-verse event but it is cool and
the weird thing is that minerva is one
of those characters marvel just never
really updated her so to get a guy's
perspective minerva was a character who
was basically a member of the cree race
and she traveled to earth to meet the
original captain marvel of the cree the
guy and then wanted to bang him in order
to basically jump start the cree's
evolution the reason why is because at
one point in their history the cree had
gotten their hands on something called
the crystal of ultimate vision but
because they wanted to use it for
nefarious purposes it basically froze
their evolutionary state so they never
aged marvel fixed that with a story
called operation galactic storm where
basically the cree race was almost
totally obliterated and because of that
their evolution was forced and so there
really isn't a need for minerva to exist
anymore that's why you see her here and
there occasionally but she never matters
because marvel never changed the
motivation it's like she never knew that
operation galactic storm happened right
i don't know how she didn't know she was
there when it did but nonetheless it's
one of those one of those weird little
things this matters because the whole
situation with this going on with
minerva actually gets the attention of
basically kamala khan of miss marvel and
she's a great character i love the
character of miss marvel her basically
stepping in and intervening actually
leads to her and spider-man teaming up
which is cool but kamala khan is one of
these characters where she had basically
come about as a result of the terrigen
bomb detonating so prior to the events
of what was going on here with
spider-verse what you had it was a story
called infinity which was part of a
larger story that dealt with the
incursions and we'll talk about that
here in a little bit but infinity was
really its own self-contained story so
you can read that of its own accord and
actually not read anything else
involving hickman's avengers and new
avengers and for the most part be fine
he'll probably have to do a little bit
of internet researching to kind of get
caught up on some things that don't make
sense but the overall gist here is that
thanos had formed the coal obsidian and
was basically traveling around the
multiverse trying to find his offspring
and kill him that eventually led him to
earth where he learned his child existed
among the inhumans he ended up getting
in a fight with black bull and in the
conflict one of the most amazing moments
in the story dude there's this amazing
moment in infinity dude i love this
moment it's like one of the best moments
ever where like thanos is fighting black
bolt he was like tell me where my son is
and black bolts like no right like any
time he talks it's a quasi-sonic scream
so like he basically you know just
emanates this massive amount of energy
like this huge concussive blast and like
he's like screaming at thanos and it's
not working and thanos is like fine keep
your secrets carry them with you to the
grave and like smashes his head in the
ground it's just a ridiculously amazing
moment but in any event uh basically
black bolt detonated the terrigen bomb
which spread pterogenesis across the
world and then all these people who
carry the inhuman genes and didn't know
it suddenly went into a state of terror
genesis quite literally they were just
like kind of encased in these ugly
looking cocoons and then they would just
manifest in whatever form it happened to
take right very similar to how mutants
suddenly just develop powers based on
their ex gene usually during like
puberty or high levels of stress but
kamala khan is one of those now what
made kamala khan so cool in her early
stories by g willa wilson is one the
family dynamic right the fact that she
came from a very traditional family but
she actually wanted to do like very
american things which were considered to
be very much against what her family
stood for but she was also like really
new to the superhero scene so like
meeting heroes for the first time and
then basically just fangirling it was
hilarious
i love the original run of of uh kamala
khan and so that's why when like
spider-man shows up she's like you're
spider-man holy cow i'm gonna i'm gonna
team up with spider-man this is amazing
and then she starts asking him stuff
like did you really go on a date with
miss marvel with like carol danvers like
what was she like what kind of music
does she dig she's like the ultimate
carol danvers fan girl but it was a it
was a cool little thing of course she
really became you know kind of stepped
into her own and became a more
solidified character but one of the
things that minerva's doing is that
because she's trying to like jump start
creep physiology she basically ends up
taking this kind of inhuman and then
seemingly bonding them with cree dna for
the purpose of like allowing them to
manifest and kind of go forward
accordingly what follows after this
isn't really interesting at all um they
fight the thing and then they basically
win and like the days save and you got
some cool moments where some stuff
happens in all honesty it's basically
filler to justify the existence of the
comic uh to basically fill it up with
space one of the things that does happen
here is you actually end up seeing cindy
moon fashioning like an official costume
for herself probably one of the more
popular costumes that exists in the
spider universe but basically that
everything's kind of cool and
everything's copacetic and you know the
day's saved and that's basically it the
meat and potatoes of this and the real
takeaway from this comes by way of
spider uk and again these are the kind
of backup features that you saw during
these events of of spider-man that
largely dealt with uh basically the
spider-verse event kind of leading into
the whole thing and so what ends up
happening here is that you basically
have a kind of situation where spider uk
almost has this kind of experience like
something's wrong in the multiverse
involving the various spiderman and in
fact he's actually using the ability to
scan the multiverse to essentially
figure all this stuff out now there's a
few things we have to explain in terms
of why this happens so spider uk is part
of what's called the captain britain
core and his name is billy braddock so
the captain britain core is a
multiversal team for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with this if you guys
know about it bear with me here for a
second i feel like we're gonna get a lot
of new viewers who have never heard of
this before the captain britain core is
a multiversal superhero team they're not
particularly powerful but take the green
lanterns from like the dc comics
universe and make it a multiversal team
and that's basically the captain britain
core there's officially one captain
britain for each universe and what they
have is something called the lighthouse
which is like their base of operations
but it's also an interdimensional
teleportation device and it allows them
to enter into what's called the
starlight citadel that's basically the
base of operations for a woman named
saturnine who's called the omniversal
magistrix her job is to like monitor the
multiverse and make sure things don't
pop off a lot of people do that the
living tribunal does that altezza the
custodian of the multiverse does that
and saturnine does that and there's even
more people who do that as well but
because of what's going on because of
the nature of the starlight citadel and
even the nature of the lighthouse itself
there is technology there that allows
members of the captain britain corps to
scan the multiverse and to see what's
going on because of what use would they
be as a team if they weren't able to
like communicate with each other
different things like that and so what
ends up happening is billy braddock
actually looks into an alternate reality
which is earth 1983 in new york city and
basically sees that in that universe
that more lun is there and it's actually
killing one of the spider-man and
absorbing their power right taking this
guy out the crazy thing about this is
this is seemingly a universe where
things were basically just cool no one
really fought it was pretty
light-hearted so this guy's overcome
pretty easily because evil doesn't
really seem to be something that exists
so quite literally he's encountering
something he's never encountered before
and so literally like all these folks
are killed at the hands of morlan and
then that's it following that he
actually starts looking through all
these different realities that you've
got two of the other inheritors that we
saw in the last video the brother and
sister bricks and bora who are actually
killing one of these spider totems as a
cat and this alternate universe that you
actually end up switching over to deimos
in earth 7831 that guy is consuming
actually an entire world full of
anthropomorphic heroes largely
consisting of the knights of wondergore
which are basically uh individuals who
were created by the high evolutionary by
basically modifying animal dna and they
kind of spread out into the world and
seemingly populated this world with
anthropomorphic animals partly and then
also baseline humans while the
inheritors themselves are only supposed
to feed on spiders if a being has super
powers and they are animal in nature
they're part of that animal totem system
so that's the reason why like moore lund
fought black panther as an example uh
they can feed on those but by way of the
instruction given to them by their
father they're not supposed to they're
only supposed to feed on spider totems
the other thing about this is you
actually have genix who's who's kind of
like the scientific arm of the
inheritors who actually realizes that
that billy braddock is spying on them
that this spider-man uk is watching them
from some other place in the multiverse
and so of course you know spider you
know billy braddock is told like we're
gonna get you you know that kind of a
thing but following that he basically
takes off and he goes to meet with roma
and saturnin now roma is the daughter of
merlin like the merlin from arthurian
legend right like he's literally the one
who founded the captain britain core the
starlight citadel all that kind of stuff
he's the one that basically spearheaded
all those things now while all this is
going on with spider-verse you also have
the incursions universes crashing into
each other basically the collapse of the
multiverse that's the first and foremost
pressing threat that's the most
important thing keeping the multiverse
from collapsing but where you end up
having like like literally billy
braddock who shows up here and tells
saturnine all the different spider-man
and spider-woman across the multiverse
are being killed by the inheritors she
doesn't care she's like that's the least
of my concerns entire universes are
being destroyed cosmic entities are
vanishing right the multiverse is
collapsing the least of my concerns are
a bunch of spider-man and spider-man
being killed by a crazy family that i
have i have no concern about that now
that's kind of the nature of saturnine
she's just kind of a dick right that's
just kind of the nature of her she's
pretty crass pretty rude there's very
much like my way or the highway that
kind of thing roma was a far more
nurturing hand and that's why she's the
one that listens to the appeal of billy
braddock when he says like we have to do
something about these and her response
is look we can't divert the efforts of
the entire captain britain core to
basically help you deal with with you
know the spider totems i can help you
out by giving you a device that'll let
you basically travel through the
multiverse but that's the extent of it
kind of the irony of all this all these
guys in the captain britain corps they
get annihilated when they meet the
beyonders oh dude the beyonders just
eradicate these guys and i think it's
really more the map makers and the
beyonders themselves but it doesn't
matter right like the the forces of the
beyonders these guys get crushed the
only member of the captain written core
who lives is brian braddock from the
maine marvel universe the captain
britain court never had a chance and in
like a last-ditch effort saturnine opens
a portal she throws brian braddock
through it gives them all the
information and the portal shuts and
that's the end of the captain britain
core right they they never stood a
chance but ultimately spider uk is given
this ability to basically travel through
the multiverse and this is a huge asset
because while he doesn't necessarily
have all the resources of the captain
britain core at his disposal right now
he has a lot of experience with
understanding the multiverse and that in
and of itself is a pretty big thing
because that will go a long way and
basically helping the forces of of uh
spider-man 2099 and superior spider-man
and all those guys in dealing with the
inheritors now at this point we switch
over to our last little tidbit here
which is kind of leads into the official
edge of spite of our story but we
basically end up picking up with mayday
parker which is essentially earth 982
now mayday parker is a fan favorite
people absolutely love her character she
originally appeared in a what if story
back in 1997 the what if story centered
around the idea of like peter parker and
mary jane watson having a kid and
actually being able to raise that kid
there was a point where peter parker in
that alter universe basically lost his
leg and uh he ended up retiring and then
once his daughter made a sort of
developing powers he started training
her to become a superhero which is
pretty cool and that's basically what
goes on here right it's the return of
mayday parker after a pretty lengthy
absence in marvel comics but the whole
thing about this is you've basically got
one of the inheritors which is actually
damos literally attacking peter parker
of this reality and then attacking
mayday as well as mary jane parker and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because none of these guys really have a
chance here right the power of the
inheritors they overcome them all now
mayday was one of those characters where
like she was one part fun but she also
had it where it counted she was the girl
you wanted in your corner when things
started popping off she would always try
to find a way right this girl had like
just non-stop optimism and so despite
the fact that it's basically a losing
battle this version of peter parker
fights damos as best he can but in the
end he knows it's basically just a
distraction his goal is to not actually
defeat damos i mean if he does he'll
certainly be like yeah great i mean he
wants to defeat the guy but he also
knows it's probably not going to happen
damos is just too strong too powerful
too fast he's just he's far beyond the
powers of just a normal spider spider
person right spider-man spider woman
what have you and so the the instruction
here is actually for mayday to basically
grab mary jane and her younger brother
and herself and to get out of there as
fast as she possibly can right to leave
is peter sacrificing his life to save
his family and so ultimately what ends
up happening is mary jane hands the baby
the the younger brother of mayday over
to mayday herself and says get out of
here right i'm right behind you
everything's gonna be cool and then mary
jane seemingly tries to stay to fight
now that was always a testament to the
nature of mary jane watson in the early
days of marvel comics and when i say the
early days i mean like mary jane as a
character when it was peter parker and
gwen stacy mary jane was always kind of
there but she seemed really shallow she
seemed like there wasn't a whole lot of
depth to her she seemed very
self-absorbed and the idea is that when
gwen stacy died there was a moment there
in the comics it was beautifully written
there was a moment there in the comics
when peter lashes out at mary jane and
then mary jane chooses to stay and that
formed the relationship there that the
two of them falling in love and then it
was really like jerry conway and those
guys that followed suit reworking and
crafting mary jane watson into a person
they became a lot more responsible a lot
more concerned a person that genuinely
cared about peter parker which she
always kind of did but she was far less
self-absorbed this is kind of like the
the fruition of that right the totality
of that what would that version of mary
jane watson look like if her and peer
parker had gotten married they had a kid
all that kind of stuff and so that's why
the family dynamic of these characters
is so cool of course mayday basically
takes off with half of her mind knowing
her mom's gonna stay behind and that's
exactly what happens right both her mom
and her dad are basically killed there
is a bit of hope for her that like peter
parker survives but what you end up
having is the arrival of the forces of
like superior spider-man and those guys
to rescue mayday parker and what she's
like well i mean it's like it's like we
can go save my dad the response is no
your dad's gone like we arrived here too
late peter parker's dead that's when
damos comes out it's like yeah i absorb
the powers of peter parker he's totally
killed like there's no one here to save
you now either you can stay here and die
or you can flee as fast as you can but
understand there's nowhere you can go we
will find you no matter where you go in
this multiverse and so that kind of sets
in stone this notion or this idea of
mayday parker to take out the inheritors
no matter what it takes no matter what
happens she wants to come out on top of
this that's a huge motivation for a
character going into the future of the
story but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end god
i love spider-verse it's such a great
story so again following this we'll go
into edge of spider-verse where we'll
get the really really cool origin
stories for a lot of these characters
but thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
you